[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXANDRE PASSOS: I'm
Alex, and I'm here
to tell you about how
you're going to build graphs
in TensorFlow 2.0.
And this might make you
a little uncomfortable,
because we already spent
quite some time earlier today
telling you that
in TensorFlow 2.0,
we use eager
execution by default.
So why am I taking
that away from you?
And I'm not.
You still have your eager
execution by default,
but graphs are useful
for quite a few things.
The two ones that I care
the most about personally
are that some hardware,
like our TPUs,
really benefit from the kind
of full program optimization
that we can get
if we have graphs.
And if you have graphs,
you can take your model
and deploy it on servers and
deploy it on mobile devices
and deploy it on
whatever thing you want,
make it available to as many
people as you can think of.
So at this point,
you're probably, eh, I
remember TensorFlow 1.0.
I remember the kind of code
I had to write to use graphs,
and I wasn't proud of it.
Is he just going to tell me
that I have to keep doing that?
And no.
One of the biggest changes
we're doing with TensorFlow 2.0
is we're fundamentally
changing the programming
model with which you build
graphs in TensorFlow.
We're removing that
model where you first add
a bunch of nodes to a graph
and then rely on session.run
to prune things
out of the graph,
to figure out the
precise things you want
to run in the correct
order and replacing it
with a much simpler model based
on this notion of a function.
We're calling it tf.function,
because that's the main API
entry point for you to use it.
And I'm here to tell you
that with tf.function,
many things that you're used
to are going to go away.
And I dearly hope you're
not going to miss them.
The first one that
goes away that I really
think no one in this
room is going to miss
is that you'll never have
to use session.run anymore.
[APPLAUSE]
So if you've TensorFlow
with eager execution,
you know how it works.
You have your tensors and
you have your operations,
and you pass your tensors
to your operations,
and the operations execute.
And this is all very
simple and straightforward.
And tf.function is just
like an operation except one
that you get to define
using a composition
of the other operations in
TensorFlow however you wish.
Once you have your
tf.function, you can call it.
You can call it inside
another function.
You can take its gradient.
You can run it on the GPU,
on the TPU, on the CPU,
on distributed
things, just like how
you would do with any
other TensorFlow operation.
So really, the way you should
think about tf.function
is we're letting you define
your own operations in Python
and making it as easy as
possible for you to do this
and trying to preserve as many
of the semantics of the Python
programming language that
you already know and love
and when you execute these
functions in a graph.
So obviously, the first
thing you would think
is that is it actually faster?
And if you look
at models that are
large convolutions or big
matrix multiplications,
large reductions, it's
not actually any faster,
because you get
executions plenty fast.
But as your models get small,
and as the operations in them
get small, you can
actually measure
the difference in performance.
And here, I show that for this
tiny lstm_cell with 10 units,
there is actually
a tenfold speed up
if we used tf.function versus
if you don't use tf.function
to execute it.
And as I was saying, we
really try to preserve as much
of the Python
semantics as we can
to make this code easy to use.
So if you've seen
TensorFlow graphs,
you know that they are
very much not polymorphic.
If you built a
graph for float64,
you cannot use it for float32
or, God forbid, float16.
But tf.function--
but Python code
tends to be very free into the
types of things it accepts.
With tf.function,
we do the same.
So under the hood, when
you call a tf.function,
we look at the tensors
you're passing as inputs
and then try to see,
have we already made
a function graph that is
compatible with those inputs?
If not, we make a new one.
And we hide this from
you so that you can just
use your tf.function as you
would use normal TensorFlow
operation.
And eventually, you'll get all
the graphs you need built up,
and your code will
run blazingly fast.
And this is not
completely hidden.
If you want to have
access to the graphs
that we're generating,
you can get them.
We expose them to you.
So if you need to manipulate
these graphs somehow or do
weird things to them
that I do not approve,
you can still do it.
But really, the main reason why
we changed this model is not
to replace session.run
with tf.function,
it's that by changing
the promise for what
we do to your code, we can
do so much more for you
than we could do before.
With the model where you add
a bunch of notes to a graph
and then prune them, it's very
hard for the TensorFlow runtime
to know what order do you want
those operations to be executed
in.
Almost every TensorFlow
operation is stateless
so that doesn't matter.
But for the few ones
where it does matter,
you probably had to use
control dependencies
and other complicated
things to make it work.
So again, I'm here to tell
you that you will never
have to use control
dependencies again
if you're using tf.function.
And how can I make
this claim happen?
So the premise
behind tf.function
is that you write code that
you'd like to run eagerly,
we take it and we make it fast.
So as we trace your Python
code to generate a graph,
we look at the
operations you run,
and every time we see
a stateful operation,
we add the minimum necessary
set of control dependencies
to ensure that all
the resources accessed
by those stateful operations
are accessed in the order you
want them to be.
So if you have two variables
and you're updating them,
we'll do that in parallel.
When you have one variable and
you're updating it many times,
we'll order those updates
so that you're not
surprised by them happening
out of order or something
like that.
So there's really
no crazy surprises
and weird, undefined behavior.
And really, you
should never need
to explicitly add control
dependencies to your code.
But you'll still get
the ability of knowing
what order things execute.
And if you want something to
execute before somebody else,
just put that line of code
above that other line of code.
You know, how you do
in a normal program.
Another thing that
we can dramatically
simplify in
tf.function is how you
use variables in TensorFlow.
And I'm sure you've all
used variables before.
And you know that while
they're very useful--
they allow you to share
state across devices,
they let you
persist, checkpoint,
do all those things, it
can be a little finicky.
Things like initializing
them is very hard, especially
if you're using your
variables of any kind
of non-trivial initialization.
So another thing that we're
removing from TensorFlow
is the need to manually
initialize variables yourself.
And the story for variables
is a little complicated,
though, because
as you try to make
code compatible with both eager
execution and graph semantics,
you very quickly
find examples where
it's unclear what we should do.
My favorite one is this one--
if you run this code
in TensorFlow 1.x,
and you session.run
repeatedly, the result,
you're going to get a series
of numbers that goes up.
But if you run
this code eagerly,
every time you run
it, you're going
to get the same number
back, because we're
creating a new variable,
updating it, and then
destroying it.
So if I wanted to
turn this code-- wrap
this code with tf.function--
which one should it do?
Should it follow the 1.x
behavior or the eager behavior?
And I think if I took a
poll, I would probably
find that you don't
agree with each other.
I don't agree with myself,
so this is an error.
Nonambiguous at
creating variables,
though, is perfectly OK.
So as you've seen
in an earlier slide,
you can create the
variable and capture it
by closure in a function.
That's a way a lot of
TensorFlow code gets written.
This just works.
Another way you can do is
like write your function such
that it only creates variables
the first time it's called.
This is incidentally what
most libraries in TensorFlow
do under the hood.
This is how Keras
layers are implemented,
how the TF 1.x layer
is implemented,
Sonnet, and all sorts
of other libraries
that use TensorFlow variables.
They try to take care
to not create variables
every time they're
called, otherwise you're
creating way too many variables,
and you're not actually
training anything.
So code that behaves well just
gets turned into function,
and it's fine.
And if you've seen
this, I didn't actually
need to call the initializer
for this variable
that I'm creating,
and it's even better.
I can make the
initializer depend
on the value of the
arguments to the function
or the value of other
variables in arbitrarily
complicated ways.
And because we control--
we add the necessary
control dependencies
to ensure that the state
updates happen in the way you
want them to happen.
There is no need for
you to worry about this.
You can just create
your variables,
like how you would use in a
normal programming language.
And things will behave the
way you want them to behave.
Another thing that I'm really
happy about tf.function
is our autograph integration.
And if anyone here has used
Control Flow in TensorFlow,
you probably know that
it can be awkward.
And I'm really happy to tell
you that with Autograph,
we're finally breaking up with
tf.cond and tf.while_loop.
And now, you can just write
code that looks like this--
so if you see here,
I have a while loop,
where the predicate depends on
the value of a tf.reduce_sum
on a tensor.
This is probably the
worst way to make a tensor
sum to 1 that I could think of.
But it fits in a slide.
So yay.
If you put this
in a tf.function,
we'll create a graph
and we'll execute it.
And this is nice.
This is great.
But how does it work?
Under the hood, things like
tf.cond and tf with our while
loop are still there, but we
wrote this Python compiler
called Autograph that rewrites
Control Flow expressions
into something that
looks like this--
yes.
Something that looks
like this, which is not
like how you would
want to write code.
And this then can be
taken by TensorFlow
and turned into fast
dynamic graph code.
So how does this work?
To explain that, I like to take
a step back and think about
how does anything
in TensorFlow work?
So you can have
a tensor, and you
can do tensor plus tensor
times other tensor, et cetera.
Just use a tensor as you'd
use a normal Python integer
or floating point number.
And how do we do that?
I'm sure you all
know this, but Python
has a thing called
operator overloading that
lets us change the behavior
of standard Python operators
when applied on our custom
data types, like tensors.
So we can override the
__add, __sub, et cetera,
and change how
TensorFlow does addition,
subtraction of tensors.
This is all fine and dandy, but
Python does not let us override
__if.
Indeed, that's not an
operator in Python.
It makes me very sad.
But if you think about
it for a few seconds,
you can probably come up with
rewrite rules that would let
us, like, lower to byte
code that would have __if
overwritable.
So for example, if code
looks like this, if condition
a else b, you could
conceptually write this
as condition.if a and b.
You would need to do some
fiddling with the scopes,
because I'm sure you know that
Python's lexical scoping is not
really as lexical
as you would think,
and names can leak
out of scopes.
And it's kind of a little
messy, but that's also
a mechanical transformation.
So if this is potentially a
mechanical transformation,
let's do this mechanical
transformation.
So we wrote this Python
to TensorFlow compiler
called Autograph
that does this--
it takes your Python code, and
it rewrites it in a form that
lets us call __if, __while,
et cetera on tensors.
This is all it
does, but this just
unlocks a lot of the power
of native Python Control Flow
into your TensorFlow graphs.
And you got to choose.
So for example, on this
function here, I have two loops.
One, it's a static Python loop,
because I write for i in range.
I is an integer, because
a range returns integers.
Autograph sees this,
leaves it untouched.
So you've still got
to use Python Control
Flow to choose how many layers
a network's going to have
and constructing
dynamically or iterate over
a sequential, et cetera.
But when your Control
Flow does depend
on the properties of tensors,
like in the second loop for i
in tf.range, then Autograph
sees it and turns it
into a dynamic tf.while loop.
This means that
you can implement
something like a dynamic
or an n in TensorFlow
in 10 lines of
code, just like how
you would use in a normal
language, which is pretty nice.
And anything really that you
can do in a TensorFlow graph,
you can make happen dynamically.
So you can make your prints and
assertions happen dynamically
if you want to debug.
But just use in
tf.print and tf.Assert.
And notice here
that I don't need
to add control dependencies
to ensure that they happen
in the right order,
because of the thing
that we were talking earlier.
We already do this, like,
we've tried these control
dependencies
automatically for you
to try to really
make your code look
and behave the same as
Python code would look like.
But all that we're doing here
is converting Control Flow.
We're not actually compiling
Python to TensorFlow graph,
because the TensorFlow runtime
right now is not really
powerful enough to support
everything that Python can do.
So for example, if
you're manipulating
lists of tensors at
runtime, you should still
use a tensor array.
It's a perfectly
fine data structure.
It works very well.
It compiles down to very
efficient TensorFlow code
and CPUs, GPUs, TPUs.
But you no longer need to
write a lot of the boilerplate
associated with it.
So this is how you stack a bunch
of tensors together in a loop.
So wrapping up, I
think we've changed
a lot in TF 2.0,
how we build graphs,
how we use those graphs.
And I think you'll all
agree that these changes are
very big.
But I hope you'll agree with
me that those changes are
worth it.
And I'll just quickly
walk you through a diff
of what your code
is going to look
like before and after this.
So session.run goes away.
Control dependencies go away.
Variable initialization
goes away.
Combed and while loop go away,
and you just use functions,
like how you would use in a
normal programming language.
So thank you, and
welcome to TF 2.0.
[APPLAUSE]
All the examples on
these slides, they run.
If you go on
tensorflow.org/alpha and you
dig it a little, you'll find a
colab notebook that has these
and a lot more, which will
play around with tf.function
and Autograph.
[MUSIC PLAYING]